they got bigger afterwards and i don't
think they
all those open world games like vice
city was the perfect size yeah you need
different parts of town but i don't need
multiple states no i don't exactly san
andreas i was like i don't want to go to
nevada i'm chilling dude exactly i was
reading some lists and they're like oh
san andreas you can tell the asphalt's
worn the detail of the game yeah no bro
i don't give a [ __ ] about that vice
city's sick dude they got great music
give me the point
and the characters look cooler because
they're all dressed in like yeah like
sick 80s like suits and she can drive
boats and it was also the first one i
don't know if it ever got enough if it
probably didn't deserve the heat because
i don't think the video games are
responsible but like that was like one
of the most school shooter games ever
too you go into the strip club with the
uh
[ __ ] the minigun and you just mow
them all down i i was never that sick i
was dude oh you're twisted that's me bro
you check out what your yeah
was and if you killed enough people to
be like